what's the most popular game on steam
play your unknown battlegrounds
well it must be a great game then
this is the worst [ __ ] game i ever
[ __ ] play
[Music]
so the goal of the game of a hundred
people
be the last man standing on this [ __ ]
island
all right here we go
give me a gun oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] don't shoot don't shoot i'm
innocent
i'm innocent i just want to hug you
this [ __ ] time i'm gonna [ __ ] do
it
are you kidding me
you guys come here often no
is that markiplier oh my god how do i
look
oh my god
[Music]
here we go oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] come on i
was reaching for my corn flakes
come on
what have i done i'm so sorry
i got nothing i have nothing
stop this is the [ __ ] one
[Music]
got him
i never even got a [ __ ] top 30. all
right
here we go
this game is easy just
going to lose these swedish [ __ ]
homes there we go i'll take that [ __ ]
give me that give me that [ __ ] boy
i saw a bunch of people land over here
i'm literally gonna rush him
oh oh i killed him
[ __ ] ranger on the shotgun man
got him i'll be taking all your [ __ ]
thank you very much
that's right thank you thank you very
much
i'm still gonna rush him
oh there's definitely someone in here oh
[ __ ]
can hear that [ __ ]
see upstairs yes
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
ass [ __ ] what's he doing
i'm just gonna just gonna check my
emails down here don't worry about it
just
making sure everything's fine
this is not camping this is uh
making sure the staircase is safe
you never know a lot of people forget to
clean out
i'm so [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he's waiting for me
please don't hurt me
i'm swedish
i should probably just make him want to
kill me
i'm not camping just making sure
you can jump off the balcony yeah
boy what you gonna do huh
right in the [ __ ] head i almost said
titty
all right what do you got on you boy
that's right i'll be taking this and
this and this
and this and this and and
got a [ __ ] frying pan
domo arigato
scope up
no all right well [ __ ] it looks like a
swedish little village doesn't it
okay let's go out
out into the world
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] don't shoot
dope well he can't [ __ ] aim oh [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] is he
where is he there he is i see him i see
him i see him i see him
i'm gonna scope him out he doesn't know
that i saw him
there he is look at him [ __ ] kick
okay i got one hit
[ __ ] where'd he go
i'm gonna go around hopefully he doesn't
expect it
might be a stupid [ __ ] move where is
he
come on [ __ ]
okay i think he's hiding
that's fine i can smell his fear
it's been my viking blood oh he's in the
building he's in the building
i think he knows i'm outside i don't
[ __ ] see him though
you must have heard me i don't know what
the [ __ ] to do what do i do
there he is okay all right all right
papa pierce
it's coming for you boy you better
spread your ass for me boy
so i got a shotgun i don't want to die
now
okay clear you probably heard me
it's in here no
die
yeah got him
hell yeah you got [ __ ] by the porter
pie i'll take this
hey you got red bull thank you oh a new
vest
i have that oh nice pants
not for me though
more ammo
[ __ ] i don't know where anything is
i hear someone i i think i did
stay in the building again yeah
someone's definitely in the building
[ __ ] me man
you hear that wooden floor so well
and they're [ __ ] upstairs [ __ ] the
map is getting smaller i gotta move
but i know he's in there
oh oh oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god i'm out i'm out i'm done i'm
[ __ ] done
i'll pick my battles all right i'll pick
my [ __ ] battle shut the [ __ ] up
did he see me [ __ ] we gotta move
otherwise we're gonna die
[ __ ] you know what i'm just gonna run
for it
call me a swedish [ __ ]
or a fig i'm out all right
if anything i learned is you gotta pick
your battles man
sayonara [ __ ] he's probably
looking for me still
[ __ ]
all right we got a lot of running today
[ __ ] we're so far away god damn it
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you see
what the [ __ ] was he doing
what the [ __ ] did he not see me did he
just park
in front of me i'll take that and all
right ah thank you
hey a police oh look how much ammo
the [ __ ] was that
my character looks so [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right well uh thanks for the car
buddy appreciate it
[Laughter]
ah [ __ ] no stop i didn't know it was
your friend
i'm [ __ ] out of here
stop shooting me
i didn't do anything
this feels a lot like half-life when
you're driving that bungee or whatever
in like russian landscapes or some [ __ ]
except this is real
this is real life i'm getting shaky man
all right let's chill here for a while
oh [ __ ] sake all right we gotta move
again
circle so it's getting smaller
okay i don't know where i should go
oh should i [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it
[ __ ] what the hell was he doing it looks
like a [ __ ] team fortress
character [ __ ] i really thought i would
die there
that was so [ __ ] bad jesus christ
those are my glasses [ __ ] all right
time to move again
gotta get back into that white circle
[ __ ] it's small now it's 23 people alive
i'm gonna go to the buildings
come on i want to make a top 10 at least
then i'll be happy
i like this strategy just going around
with a bungee
okay hopefully they'll come some people
from here
oh too far
i'm playing it safe
it's not called being a [ __ ] it's
called being
a [ __ ] i'm kidding [ __ ] sake here's
someone
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
god damn it
come on shut up foam
i can't die now
i just can't
it's not camping okay shut up
i just don't want to [ __ ] die
[ __ ] where'd he go i think he chickened
out as well there he is
come out and play boy [ __ ] i can't aim
god damn it oh [ __ ] i gotta move
oh [ __ ] ah [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] what do i do oh there is there's
aim
die what the [ __ ] is he doing
[Applause]
oh my god how is he alive
[ __ ] i gotta blink i'm wearing my
contact lenses
[ __ ] okay i gotta move third i got 30
seconds
come on boy seven people alive
i'm going for my car
is there any other place to [ __ ] go
i never met six people alive i never
made it this far
god damn boy i'm in the circle
i should there's a house here well
that's my [ __ ] house now
thank you is anyone here
i think i'm the first one
this this circle is getting so tiny five
people
i'm [ __ ] closing this [ __ ] this shop
is closed
boys we serve only meatballs
and now we play the waiting game
oh it's getting oh it's already getting
smaller
[ __ ] it's tiny
circle is so tiny
i thought i heard someone
oh who the [ __ ] say hi in my house
[ __ ] i gotta make it over there what do
i do
i don't know where to go i'm panicking
here guys how they fight people in this
tiny [ __ ] area
god damn i'm scared i'm so [ __ ]
scared
come on boy 30 seconds [ __ ]
okay i'm going do i take the car what do
i do
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] get up don't
shoot me
ah
come on come on come on come on come on
yes
[ __ ] you you're sneaking that butt
he was waiting for me that [ __ ]
there's three people alive
oh [ __ ] it's me i'm drinking a [ __ ]
red bull there's me and one are the
[ __ ] guy
in this circle right now out of 100
people
i'm [ __ ] shaking i'm about to [ __ ]
myself bro
he can't be behind me he must be here
somewhere
that's a rock look how tiny this [ __ ]
[ __ ] is
there's no way he can be there [ __ ] what
do i do
i'm panicking i'm gonna be so [ __ ]
pissed if i die now i swear to [ __ ]
god
[ __ ] well i'm still in the circle
but damn it's getting tiny
where is he where the [ __ ] is he
i see him i see him i see him that's
snake
come on
best game i'm the best player alive
[ __ ]
that's why you thought i couldn't do it
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] this game i'm uninstalling never
playing this [ __ ] again
[ __ ] you